-Now I thought I would share
some of my favorite
#IfIWonTheLottery stories
from you guys.
This first one's
from @Jerrikaswag.
She says, "I would get Britney
Spears and her backup dancers
to come to my house
and sing 'Work Bitch'
while my kids did their chores."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
-This one's from @Kevintjackson.
He says, "I would pay Morgan
Freeman to move in with me
and narrate my activities."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"He ordered that pad Thai again
for dinner."
This one's from @Kristinrose124.
She says, "I'd hold
a 'Bachelorette'-style
rose ceremony
for every person I know
where they find out
if they made the cut
to be part of
my awesome rich life."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Sorry, Kayla,
you're not getting a rose."
This one's from @Daveholmestv.
-Yeah!
-He says, "I would finally get
my own HBO Go subscription
and stop using
my ex's password."
Hey!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Small goals.
-This one is from @ewokabby.
-Yeah.
-She says, "I would pay off
my student loans
and then with the extra $4 left,
I'd buy a bean crunchwrap
supreme from Taco Bell."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's not bad.
That might be the best one.
-Yeah, that's the best one.
-This one's from @wooddr0.
He says,
"I would buy a rocket ship,
fill it with all the mosquitos,
then launch it directly
into the sun."
Yeah!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Mosquitos.
This last one's
from @Chrisorem10.
He says, "I would fly
some people who believe
the Earth is flat to outer space
just so I could point at
the Earth
and be like, 'Look, dumbass.'"
There you go. There are your
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.